in every story there is a hero and a  villain in your story you're both all  the bright aspects and all the dark  aspects of yourself orchestrate the  melody of your song a song that you need  to hear first before anyone else but in  order to hear it you have to learn to  listen to listen not only to what you  want but also to what you're afraid of  your fears and your darkness aren't  detached from you do not extrude them  face them analyze them internalize them  the shadow is always there and it will  always be but the shadow can look big or  it can look small depending on the angle  from which the light caresses you what  is the size of your shadow